you've made it to the last lesson in
native language on using the IPA to
pronounce another language this time I'm
going to build on the previous videos
that introduced vowels consonants and
syllables and move on to features that
apply to longer units of speech first
off it's important to consider that when
we record speech or listen to speech we
don't actually find things like breaks
between words or pauses between
sentences we don't hear punctuation or
capital letters instead we hear a very
fluid stream of sounds there's a
linguistic term for that stream of
sounds and utterance and utterance is a
chunk of spoken language the concept of
utterances focuses on speech instead of
squeezing spoken language in two
categories proper to written language
like words and sentences and paragraphs
this plays into phonetic transcriptions
in IPA we don't need to use things like
punctuation marks word breaks or line
breaks in IPA that also leads to another
observation about speech speakers don't
make clear divisions between sounds
between the individual phonemes when
they're spoken out loud phonemes that
are pronounced next to each other tend
to become more alike this is a process
known as assimilation here's an example
of assimilation with the phoneme n the N
in the word lain has the alveolar nasal
hmm but the N in language has the velar
nasal mmm notice that mm comes before
the velar stop good this n has
assimilated to the velar sound that
comes after it
I'm telling you that mm and in are two
different sounds in the words lane and
language however if you're an English
speaker you probably think that these
two sounds are simply versions of the
same sound
they're both n sounds this points to an
abstract concept the concept of
allophones versus underlying phony
in these examples hmm and mm are to
allophones of the same underlying
phoneme the abstract phoneme is n but
it's realized in different contexts by
different allophones elephone is a Greek
word for other sound and that's really
the way that a speaker of a language
hears different sounds as versions of
the same sound we can visually
distinguish phonemes from allophones in
IPA by enclosed enclosing allophones and
brackets these two sounds enclosed in
brackets are different allophones of
that same phoneme n speech isn't just
phonemes strung together in two
syllables and utterances there are other
features one other feature is known as
accent stress accent involves saying one
syllable of a word louder than the
surrounding syllables we do this in
english with words that have a fixed
accent for instance in the word hotel
the second syllable is Proust louder
than the first on the other hand in the
word hostel the first syllable is louder
than the second so in hotel the second
syllable is given a stress accent it's
weighted stress accent is indicated in
IPA by a small straight apostrophe
before the stressed syllable like this
notice that the syllable break symbol is
dropped when the stress accent is added
words can have a pitch accent instead in
some languages pitch involves raising or
lowering the tone as in music for
instance the ancient Greek word Altos
has a high pitch on the last syllable
while the word o'donnell's has a high
pitch on the first syllable the other
syllables have a lower pitch
words can be distinguished that way we
can represent basic pitch changes in IPA
with an acute accent above high tone
valves and a grave accent above low tone
vowels we've been applying these
features at the level of syllables and
words what if we apply those features
like languages routinely due to the
level of utterances and sentences when
we get to that level we can see that we
use stress in English to differentiate I
didn't go vs. I didn't go versus I
didn't go I'm using stress to convey
emphasis or to nuance the meaning we can
consider intonation similarly English
speakers regularly use intonation at the
level of a sentence to ask a question
you raise your voice at the end of a
sentence to ask a question right and
intonation lowers at the end of a
typical statement I've just given you
examples of prosody the application of
features like intonation and stress at
the level of an entire phrase or an
entire utterance rather than at the
level of a single phoneme or a single
syllable
I've now covered the basics of vowels
consonants syllables and prosody you can
start to use your understanding of the
IPA as you learn languages check out the
web page or workbook for more practice
and move on to the intro to phonology
for a deeper understanding of how
pronunciation works all the best on your
journeys with IPA
and thanks for learning with me